c'était une icône pour toute une
génération
le 8 mai 2000 le québec qui sous le choc
en apprenant que de ses plus grands
artistes est décédé dans des
circonstances tragiques le temps un peu
apaiser la douleur mais sans effacer la
mémoire la fierté et comme revenu aussi
bien comme une espèce de passe un peu
plus pudiques aussi direct après après
les événements disons puis je me suis
rendu compte que quelques les jeunes
connaissent et connaissent les chansons
encore beaucoup
en trois albums des fortes et les
colloques se sont imposés comme l'un
sinon le groupe le plus marquant des
années 90 alléluia c'est lui qui était
l'âme central de ce projet qui était qui
étaient les colloques mais les colocs
c'était une gang de musiciens s'étaient
c'était des gens qui faisaient du cinéma
c'est ailleurs
c'étaient des armes et était toujours là
pour vous faut pour poursuivre les idées
de foi des véritables bêtes de scène
les colloques ont écrit plusieurs
grandes chansons comme julie la rue
principale
waqar cassez-vous de leur album posthume
multiples reprises et même un film de
fiction inspirée de sa vie témoigne de
la marque indélébile qu'il a laissé
c'était un vrai poète dans tous le sens
beauxis finalement que je comprenais
quand il disparu c'est qu'on venait de
perdre un poète qui sait pour une
société qu une culture si c'est vraiment
tragique
les colloques était aussi un groupe
engagé à travers son propos qui à
travers aussi une forme de rage c'est
justement ce que dédé fortin et
exprimait sa raison pour laquelle la
musique des défauts retrait pour les
membres la génération x
sa musique était vital son suicide et la
fondation qui porte son nom ont
également contribué à mettre sur le
devant de la scène la question de la
santé mentale et l'importance d'avoir de
l'aide
je m'ennuie tes yeux
dans nuit tuent des miens vingt ans plus
tard stefie shock a repris la chanson
juste une petite niche la langue des
colloques était très proche des émotions
et des émotions telles qu'on aime qu'on
les nomme ici
[Musique]
et le passage du temps ne rien enlever à
la force de ses mots ici nabi alexandre
charti radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]